good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp-783
object class
catter
special containment procedures
personnel must monitor the town of tembi
and continue to develop the entity's
profile its victims are to be retrieved
incinerated and catalogued in this file
update due to recent events a stronger
foundation presence has been determined
to be necessary for the containment of
scp-783
and its related phenomena an ancillary
building near the local hospital as well
as two domiciles have been commandeered
from the locals for foundation use
this property in its entirety has been
redesignated as a provisional site five
description
scp-783 is a hostile entity currently
preying upon the residents of tembi a
rural hamlet in oxfordshire england it
has a period of activity lasting roughly
70 days over the fall and winter months
occurring every 12 years it exclusively
attacks those who are alone and indoors
after sunset
buildings housing
scp-783's current target will experience
a steady degradation of their structural
integrity outwardly this is visible as
faults and breaks on the outer facade
which lend affected structures and
angled or crooked appearance this
anomaly extends to any objects which
breach the affected building's exterior
causing immediate and severe deformation
that is invariably fatal to living
subjects
to date personnel have yet to prevent an
attack or been able to provide any means
of assistance to scp-783's targets due
to this as well as scp-783's effects on
recording equipment little is known
regarding
scp-783's exact appearance and the
nature of its anomalous attributes
victims of scp-783 attack exhibit gross
deformations in their body structure as
the result of dozens of compound
fractures along their long bones and
severely displaced vertebrae these are
healed via the rapid generation of
excessive cartilage and osseous tissue
victims display hyperelasticity of their
epidermis and musculature to accommodate
the extra tissue with one subject's
forearm extending over 2.4 meters and
another having a recorded height of 12.5
meters the end result of this
malformation and elongation are subjects
who visually present as being wholly
serrated or gnarled
despite the nature of these injuries
most victims are alive after the
cessation of an scp-783 attack though
they often suffer full-body paralysis or
remain in a persistent vegetative state
27 living specimens have been acquired
and placed on life support they are held
in a wing of the local hospital
requisitioned for foundation use
the residents of tembi are aware of the
existence of scp-783
though speaking of it publicly is
considered taboo researchers have
documented a playground song shared
among local youths regarding the anomaly
there lived a crooked man who made a
crooked deal he kept a crooked cane and
his catching crooked creel he stole a
crooked child who cried a crooked squeal
and that little crooked man was broken
on the wheel
observation
incident log appended
a month prior to scp-783's current
period of activity d-209 was selected
from a group of volunteers to live in a
foundation-owned property in tembi audio
video recording equipment was installed
throughout the house for observation
purposes
the following was recorded on the 43rd
day of his stay
video log
2234
second floor bedroom d-209 is lying
upright in bed reading a novel
living room live feed experiences a
jagged vertical distortion in its
display this begins on the left of the
frame near the front door and crosses
over to the right side towards the
hallway it lasts approximately 23
seconds
22 35
first floor hallway floodlights from the
window opposing the camera are obscured
by something entering the hallway a
similar distortion effect occurs center
frame
masking the object the image quality
further degrades before ceasing
transmission
second floor bedroom d-209 jerks upright
alert claims to hear a slow prolonged
scratching sound coming from the first
floor he begins to get up out of bed
note
scp-783 manifestation confirmed visual
distortion taken to be an indicator of
scp-783's physical placement within the
house
2236
second floor stairs image becomes wavy
and distorted movement can be seen
though the interference is such that no
details can be made out
second floor bedroom slow deliberate
footsteps can be heard ascending the
stairs d-209 attempts to open the window
and escape to no avail
22-37
second floor bedroom d-209 procures a
small lamp from the nightstand and makes
several attempts to smash through the
window
second floor hallway sudden video
corruption affects this feed as scp-783
moves directly in front of the camera
the image resolves over the span of 33
seconds as it moves farther down the
hall at this point the only affected
area on the recording is immediately
outside the bedroom
second floor bedroom d-209 freezes a
knock is heard at the door
22 38
second floor bedroom d-209 approaches
the door wielding the lamp as a cudgel
he asks for the individual at the door
to identify themselves receiving no
response he then asks control if any
personnel were able to gain entry
observing personnel maintain radio
silence d-209 braces himself and grasps
the doorknob with his free hand d-209
throws the door open
note a loud snapping noise is heard
throughout the house all light bulbs on
the premises burst simultaneously
including floodlights focused on the
property
2240
second floor bathroom once the camera
adjusts to low light conditions scp-783
comes into view it is near the open door
to the hallway motionless
second floor bedroom d-209 is screaming
clutching his right arm it has been
fractured just above the elbow and
dangles freely it is observed to swiftly
harden presumably due to rapid bone
growth d209 shouts his intent to escape
with his life and charges from the room
second floor hallway as d-209 runs past
the bathroom a loud snapping noise is
heard d-209 falls to the ground and
screams for assistance he reports that
his leg had been broken
note video corruption instantly begins
to affect the kitchen as the sound is
made ceasing in the bathroom
2245
second floor hallway d-209 is able to
bring himself to a stand he displays his
right arm for the camera which has been
broken below the elbow it is angled in
the opposite direction from the previous
fracture d209 curses observing personnel
but reports that his pain has mostly
subsided he limps towards the stairs
second floor stares while trying to
navigate the stairs
d-209 trips and falls twelve loud snaps
are heard in rapid succession upon
coming to rest d-209 exhibits several
more fractures in various places along
each limb he screams as they set and
spasms on the landing
second floor stairs d-209 begins to
ambulate he struggles to crawl
eventually passing out of frame
2326
first floor living room
d-209 can be seen dragging himself into
the room he strains moving with great
difficulty due to his cumbersome limbs
each arm is estimated to be over 2
meters in length with several inflexible
breaks that inhibit motion around
obstacles first floor kitchen
scp-783 demanifests visual feed clears
2331
first floor living room
d-209 occupies the majority of the
living room his lower legs stretch out
of frame into the hallway he has a hand
on the knob of the front door but the
length of his fingers impairs the
dexterity required to manipulate it a
scratching sound is audible in the
hallway d-209 expresses distress
immediately before being dragged
backwards forcibly and off-camera he
begins to scream
note
scp-783 and d-209 remain in the hallway
for the duration of the night snapping
is heard intermittently d-209 ceases
screaming at 0-4-27
at 0-501 a wet suckling noise can be
heard followed by rapid thumping
incident 783.1
concurrent with the noises heard at
0.501 during the d209 trial all 27
living victims in foundation care went
into seizure
despite the fact that the majority were
brain dead or wholly paralyzed they
convulsed for several minutes two
present researchers were injured during
the incident life support systems for
several patients were compromised
killing five
a vast quantity of earth was disturbed
on the outskirts of town during this
time
update
personnel tasked with investigating the
recent seismic event were met with
resistance from tembi locals who crowded
around an area in a field to the south
of town after a brief exchange agent
collins drew her firearm and discharged
around into the air the crowd dispersed
several elongated toes were immediately
visible protruding from the freshly
exposed earth
a dig team was assembled and by the
following afternoon had unearthed a mass
grave approximately five meters across
containing several dozen nude victims of
scp-783 the bodies were well preserved
yet desiccated their number was unable
to be immediately ascertained owing to
the fact that they had been piled atop
one another they were orientated head
down with their limbs extending deeper
into the pit furthermore most of the
victims had become intertwined or
knotted around each other preventing
exumation without the use of sawing
instruments
researcher singer elected to extract a
tissue sample during this process the
soil beneath him caved and he tumbled
into the pit the body shifted due to his
weight as he struggled to gain footing
the tangle of limbs gave way and he fell
out of sight
agent collins promptly commandeered a
length of rope and tied it around her
waist she tasked several nearby
personnel with reeling her in upon her
signal and entered the pit approximately
20 meters worth of rope was drawn
beneath the corpses as agent collins
descended
the line became taught after several
minutes she signaled for extraction and
was recovered safely upon debrief the
agent testified to the existence of an
anomalous locale the entrance to which
is located beneath the victim's corpses
a temporary leave of absence was granted
to agent collins
field logs
scp-783
l1
initial d-class exploration for
observational purposes retrieval of mia
personnel secondary objective
the following is the first recorded
exploration regarding the scp-783
case file please refer to the primary
documentation for further information
field log one d 2172 is chosen to
perform preliminary observation of the
subterranean tembi anomaly a large
circular pit acting as a mass grave for
the twisted and elongated corpses of
past scp-783 victims all facing downward
d-2172 is suited in mopp
level 4 gear and fitted with a
retractable harness communication and
video recording devices were hardlined
through the tether
they were provided with a handheld photo
ionization detector a geiger counter and
other environmental testing apparatuses
they were allotted a basic survival kit
as well as a ruger lc9 and apple
ammunition
expedition was scheduled to commence at
0 800 local time but does not begin
until 08 35. this is due to a minor
issue regarding
d2172's personal protective garments
despite being of proper size for their
frame d-2172
proved incapable of fitting them on even
with the assistance of personnel larger
gear had to be supplied
transmission begins as the 2172 is being
lowered via crane over the pit of
scp-783 victims they prod their foot
into a fold between the coiled torsos of
two corpses which part they look up and
signal for the technician to continue
visual feed reduces in clarity
intermittently as limbs and bodies pass
close to the lenses twelve meters of
tether are expended before daylight is
completely obscured
[Music]
d-2172's headlamp activates nothing of
note can be seen from their position
within the knot of corpses
descent is put on hold when
d-2172 begins to thrash
d-2172 becomes insistent that command
resumed the descent and at a faster rate
they claimed to have felt a hand
caressing their back
at 18 meters
d-2172 reports a sense of vertigo and
expresses confusion regarding the
direction of travel after a brief
discussion with command it is determined
that d-2172
had experienced an inversion of gravity
d-2172 manages to reorientate themselves
and proceeds to climb upwards from their
perspective in order to continue descent
ambient light levels begin to increase
as 20 meters of tether are expended
daylight can be seen shortly thereafter
an overcast sky is captured as
d2172 breaks the surface
the surrounding area is partially
obscured however due to the countless
elongated arms extending upwards from
the mass of corpses
t2172 utilizes two of these appendages
as leverage in order to fully extricate
themselves they slowly navigate towards
solid ground
the area is seen to perfectly replicate
the town of tembi as it exists in
baseline reality
d2172 is standing in a field on the
outskirts of town to the north is a
small stone cottage belonging to a mr
john myers and beyond that the main road
into town
d2172 turns for a panorama shot sparsely
wooded areas in fields border d-2172's
location in every other direction
confirming that this replication is
absolute for as far as can be seen
thermal and atmospheric readings match
those in baseline d-2172 disengages
their harness with audio-visual feed
converting to a wireless stream via a
relay device
d2172 is then instructed to use their
photo ionization
to take a head sample of the soil
while
d-2172 is testing the sample researcher
kest notices an oddity regarding the
soil surrounding the mass grave on
d2172's and upon playing back the
footage dozens of marks can be seen in
the soft earth the pattern of these
markings suggests that they have been
created by fingers being drawn through
the ground this is noted by command
d-2172 is not informed of this
development
d-2172 reports that no contaminants have
been detected command instructs them
next to proceed to the maya's cottage
and to remain vigilant for any signs of
research a singer
d-2172 arrives at the cottage and knocks
thrice on the door they pause awaiting
an answer and then proceed to enter
the cottage appears to be uninhabited
d-2172 rummages through the first room
finding nothing of note and walks into
the bedroom on the wall over the bed is
a rough sketch done in charcoal it
depicts the upper body of a reclined
humanoid figure holding a rod or staff
its free hand is outstretched above the
headrest
d2172 is instructed to approach and
inspect the drawing the 2172 is hesitant
professing to feel a great sense of
unease while in the drawing's presence
they advance slowly with each step in
its direction comes a decrease in the
quality of the video feed which begins
to break up by the time the drawing is
within arm's reach the video feed is
obscured by heavy amounts of static the
audio is drowned out by a shrill
whistling noise before d2172 can touch
the drawing command orders them to
withdraw
they acquiesce and back away
interference is reduced to nominal
levels
d-2172 is permitted to exit the premises
and explore the village proper d-2172
walks in silence for a few minutes
before the road sign for tembi becomes
visible they travel down a bend in the
road where on the ground they find a
single work boot picking it up then
turning it over in their hands
it becomes clear that it matches those
belonging to research a singer
d-2172 intuits the direction singer
could have been traveling and points out
a nearby home
it is a two-story dwelling with a
sizable front lawn housing a witch elm
the tree is noticeably dead the ground
around it is littered with broken limbs
the front door of the abode is wide open
d-2172
heads towards it
director kim at the time acting as
command and overseeing the excursion
requests to be relieved of duty citing
the onset of a debilitating migraine
they are escorted to their quarters by
agent collins
researcher bond steps in for director
kim
d-2172 crosses the foyer and enters the
living room there are signs of previous
struggle the couch is overturned
as is a small end table there is a hole
in the wall in the bottom of the floor
d-2172 steps over the shattered remains
of a tabletop lamp and into the
adjoining kitchen
this room is in a similar state of
disarray dishes foodstuffs and
appliances that would have been on the
shelves or countertop lit to the floor
leading back to the living room most of
these items have incurred damage
suggesting that they had been stuck or
thrown with considerable force
as d2172 nears the sink a small pool of
blood can be seen on the floor there is
a clear pattern of cast off spatter on
the walls and counter with long strokes
indicating that an assailant delivered
several successive blows with a bladed
weapon
d-2172 kneels to take a sample of the
blood and upon standing a butcher's
block can be seen laying on its side
next to the sink all of the slots are
filled save for the one intended for a
meat cleaver d2172
notes this fact
a series of passive blood stains leads
from d2172's location and towards a door
on the far end of the room the door is
heavily pock-marked and scratched
indicating assault it is found to be
locked from the other side
d-2172 attempts to kick the door in
but only manages to splinter some wood
along the door frame before becoming
winded after three attempts they walk
back towards the other end of the
kitchen take a deep breath and charge at
the door
d-2172
shoulders the door at full speed
reaching it successfully their momentum
carries them over the door's threshold
where they panic and brace the wall for
support in order to stop themselves from
falling down a flight of stairs
leading to the basement
d-2172
gains their bearings and is chided for
their reckless behavior command
instructs them to enter the basement
after trying the light switch which
fails to produce a result they have a
brief discussion with command on the
merits of documenting the contents of
the basement and they place heavy
emphasis on the value of their own life
they are eventually persuaded to
continue on threat of being cast adrift
d-2172 activates their headlamp they
draw their firearm disengage the safety
and carefully descend in a low ready
stance hugging the wall opposite the
railing
the basement is largely empty
d-2172 sweeps the area and something on
the ground in the far corner of the room
glints under the light of their headlamp
the 2172 approaches and finds the
missing meat cleaver
wet with blood they kneel to inspect the
cleaver and upon standing they notice a
quarter metre wide hole in the concrete
wall an exhaust vent leading above
ground a piece of fabric is hanging from
inside it
closer inspection reveals it to be a
pant leg
d2172 pulls at their article which is
found to be a tatted pair of tan slacks
previously worn by researcher singer a
rustling is heard from within the vent
d-2172 leans in to closer inspect and
something flashy can be seen which
quickly moves up a bend in the pipe and
out of sight
d2172 promptly withdraws from the
premises
due to the discoveries within the
domicile researcher singer is presumed
to have been killed in action
d-2172 is instructed to travel out of
town in order to further document the
nature of the area itself and determine
its actual boundaries if any little of
note occurs for the next 40 minutes as
d2172
travels north and out of town down
tembi's main street
d-2172 is now outside tembe's town
limits continuing on the main road which
now winds through a densely wooded grove
of silver bunches this geography remains
consistent with that of baseline for the
following two kilometers at which point
the forest gives way to fields and is
not until a small cottage is spotted
ahead that d-2172
expresses concern
they stop and survey the surrounding
area revealing that they had somehow
emerged back on the south side of tembi
d2172 conveys to command that they
cannot see the limbs of scp-738 victims
which should have been visible extending
out of the body pit they diverge from
the path and run towards the expected
location of the victims
upon reaching it there is a large
circular area of overturned soil and a
distinct lack of corpses there are no
signs of d2172's presence here either a
previously discarded sample bag along
with the relay device and accompanying
tethered harness are absent the 2172
begins to panic and is instructed to
hold their position
while commander decides upon a course of
action
researcher bond confers with the on-hand
technician to confirm the status of
d-2172's harness it is relayed that it
had not been retracted prematurely nor
had any length of tether been expended
since d2172
set aside their harness after some
deliberation it is determined that
d2172 has possibly entered an iterative
spatial zone situated adjacent from
their original area of entry it is then
decided that exploration beyond this
point would be best handled by personnel
experienced with excursions of this
nature
d-2172 was instructed to follow the road
back towards the entry point
d-2172 is traveling down the road
through the silver birch forest at a
brisk pace idly conversing with command
it is as they remark on the absence of
any form of life that a rustle of leaves
can be heard d-2172
turns towards the source of the noise to
find the naked body of an elongated
scp-783 victim it is sprawled across the
road unmoving a few dozen meters away
d-2172
swears loudly
and then turns to continue on the path
another scp-783 victim is stretched
along the road before him some distance
away also unmoving
d-2172 withdraws their firearm
and takes a step towards it a rustling
and snapping sound can then be heard
behind d2172
who again turns to face the victim
behind them
although the body's position remains
unchanged it is clear that the trunk and
arms had grown and elongated twisting
and breaking placing them closer to
d2172's position more snapping can be
heard once again from behind d-2172
they rapidly turn and fire at the
scp-783 victim barring their path whose
neck had elongated and bent such that it
placed their head roughly a meter away
from d2172
at eye level though several rounds are
discharged directly into its face it
elicits no reaction
snapping can be heard once again from
the unobserved victim behind d2172
who absconds from between the entities
by running off the road and into the
woods
d-2172
runs for several minutes eastward
ignoring command's advice to keep the
road within view they eventually stop to
catch their breath and recuperate coming
to rest momentarily on a large rock
there is no sign of pursuit from the
scp-783 victims
d-2172 uses this opportunity to reload
their firearm upon holstering it they
take some time to consume an mre
they consult with command on their
relative position and determined the
proper direction of travel a moment is
taken to alleviate themselves and they
set off
the track is largely uneventful over the
next 14 minutes before d2172 stops they
claim to feel minute vibrations in the
ground
coming in short punctuated bursts though
they are assured that the sensation may
be attributable to the unstable region
of space-time in which they are in
something that should not be concerning
they insist on remaining still
listening they inform command of a muted
thumping noise coinciding with the
vibrations this is not picked up on
audio they advance carefully again
readying their firearm off in the
distance the camera captures a single
silver birch tree being lifted
vertically out of sight above the tree
line
d-2172 does not seem to have witnessed
it as command attempts to communicate
this to the 2172 it comes back down
through the treetops much closer to
d2172
and impacts the ground with enough force
to shake the ground
it can now be seen that despite its
thickness and mottled white coloration
that it is not in fact a birch tree from
d2172's vantage point it cannot be seen
to have any branches and it extends to a
point somewhere above the canopy d-2172
is instructed to approach and physically
inspect it before they can act upon this
another such object comes down directly
next to d2172
knocking them to the ground
once on their feet they approach the
second object they pause once again to
see the faint impression of ridges and
grooves running along the object's side
and opposite of it a flattish horny nail
plate
d-2172 fires at the object and draws
blood it quickly withdraws
a deep protracted scream emanates from
above d2172
who breaks into a run
d-2172
runs through the forest swearing
incessantly and begging for some form of
assistance or support from command as
they run more objects crash down around
them seemingly trying to hit
d2172 directly
they break from the forest
they are now on the northern outskirts
of tembi as d2172 hurries to close the
distance to town
another of the unidentified objects
collides with d2172
knocking them on their back the object
comes to rest beside d2172
taking up the majority of the visual
feed
d-2172's gaze follows the object tracing
up its length without the obstruction of
the canopy it can be seen to bend and
twist terminating several hundred meters
in the air
d-2172 screams when they discover its
source
the nude form of researchers singer is
suspended high in the air balanced on
elongated and grossly enlarged fingers
researcher bond stands from her position
at the control console doubles over and
proceeds to vomit profusely a member of
medical staff rushes to her side in time
to catch her as she falls unconscious dr
peterson elects to take her place at the
command console
agent collins arrives to help carry
researcher bond to the medical bay where
she is to receive corrective treatment
the singer creature screams a hollow
sound lifting one finger from somewhere
deep within the silver birch grove
felling several trees as they drag it
towards d2172
d-2172 rolls to their left and out of
its path
they withdraw their weapon and fire at
singer failing to hit their mark
the singer creature can then be seen to
lift its left hand slowly dragging its
digits together to grab d2172
d2172 swiftly comes to a stand and runs
in the opposite direction the digits can
be heard colliding with one another
behind them
they safely reach the main road and do
not slow their pace as they follow it
south through town loud thumping can be
heard as the singer creature ambulates
on their digits in pursuit
d-2172 narrowly avoids a finger as it
sweeps past them to the right crashing
through a chain-link fence surrounding
one of the houses another finger
plummets through the roof of an abode
ahead of d-2172
d2172 swears repeatedly as they come
around the bend where they found
research's singer's boot they passed the
road sign nearly falling as they trip
over their own feet the 2172's pace
begins to slow as they are clearly
becoming winded the myers cottage comes
into view and shortly thereafter arms
can be seen extending out from the body
pit command encourages d2172
urging them to reach the pit and
assuring them that the technician
standing by is prepared to reel them
back in
the singer creatures screeches
d-2172
is not designed with great force
tumbling into the field visual feed is
lost due to incurred damage
d2172 can be heard screaming and
swearing with ambient volume suggesting
that they are getting farther and
farther away from the recorder the
thumping of these singer creatures
fingers can be heard becoming more and
more distant as well
silence is recorded for the final half
hour
dr peterson orders the termination of
the audio feed and declares 2172 as lost
it is decided that
d-2172's harness may be recalled for
future use
agent collins arrives in the control
room and discusses the matter with dr
peterson collins asserts that there is
no evidence that d-2172 was captured or
had expired citing an ethics committee
mandate on the exploration of
non-incursive extradimensional locales
they persuade dr peterson to leave
available
d2172's harness
several personnel remain on hand over
the next several hours at o2 13 local
time the presiding technician reports
that they witnessed the tether moving
after a moment of stillness they are
able to observe it becoming briefly
taught as the line is tugged on twice
the 2172 signal for extraction
medical personnel are notified and it is
anticipated that
d-2172 will need to be tended to after a
minute
d-2172's empty body harness breaks the
surface it appears that none of the
straps had been properly secured prior
to being recalled the harness seems to
be caught on something within the pit
the tether continues to retract
revealing the hand of d2172 grasping to
the harness which slips out of their
grip
d-2172's hand can be seen to move
animatedly attempting to grab hold of
something to keep it from slowly sinking
back into the mass of corpses
d209 rushes towards the pit grabbing
hold of
d2172's hand moments before it falls out
of sight they begin to sink into the
knot of bodies as well d-774
dr lafayette and private audi quickly
come to assist d-209 forming a human
chain and with their combined strength
begin to pull a pair of d-class from the
pit
d-209 is successfully extricated his
arms are outstretched hands still
grasping that of
d2172 whose hand comes back into view as
the formant pull approximately three
meters of
d-2172's forearm are dislodged from the
body pit it begins to bend and snap at
several new points of articulation
d209 let's go d-2172
is reclaimed by the pit
scp-783-l2
[Music]
special operative dispatched to further
ascertain the nature of scp-783
the following is a second recorded
exploration regarding the scp-783 case
file please refer to the primary
documentation for further information
field log2
due to the events which transpired
during scp-783 l1 it is determined that
the spatial zone accessible through the
nod of corpses within the town of tembi
is likely recursive being bordered on
all sides by successive iterations of
itself essentially the dimension
consists of perfect copies of a single
cell in an endless grid layout a special
operative or so would be required to
effectively traverse the locale
special operative nix is requisitioned
from site 121 in the united states she
was chosen due to her expertise in
traversing extra spatial locales
featuring recurring topology having
personally mapped 27 iterations of scp
engineered a supply line for mobile task
force tirfing black during their second
tour of scp
and having successfully navigated an
escape route through site
during an emergency extraction of assets
after a full debriefing and several
viewings of
d2172's exploration log special
operative nix spends her first week on
site personally inspecting the town
limits of baseline tembi and denoting
points of interest along the wooded
outskirts on her personal map it is only
after she had acquainted herself with
the local topography that she
requisitions materials from hq and makes
final preparations for her dive into the
tembi pit of corpses on the eighth day
special operative nix returns to the
site with the following
approximately one thousand referencing
exit markers rem
a prismatic compass and map of tembi
sufficient rations for a three-day
excursion
wireless audio visuals surveillance
camera
an m10 14 shotgun with side saddle 12
gauge buckshot times 16.
a shotgun shell bandolier 12 gauge
buckshot times 20 and 12 gauge slug
times 36
one 24 inch machete
and unit
k9121 a two-year-old dutch shepherd
tafos
agent collins is chosen to oversee
command during the excursion owing to
the sickness which had affected her
colleagues during the previous
expeditions broadcast
special operative nix spends an hour in
the evening by practicing quick load
maneuvers for her firearm by noon she is
outfitted in full tactical protective
gear both special operative nicks and
k9121 are lowered through the tembi mass
grave one after another at sunrise once
within the tembi replica special
operative nix is able to repair the
relay device installed during the first
expedition by d2172
the camera feed activates
there is a light early morning fog
permeating the air as the feed activates
special operative nix scans the
surrounding fields and farmlands
identifying no immediate threats there
is no sign of d2172
she turns and calls out to k9121 who is
partially obscured by the arms reaching
up from the body's pit tangle of corpses
as k9121 comes around to meet up with
special operative knicks it passes
beneath a low-hanging limb from one of
the bodies which breaks with an audible
crack the gnarled limb stops just short
of touching k9121
before it is swiftly severed by special
operative nix's machete
as the pair depart intermittent cracks
can be heard from the grounded appendage
as it continues to convulse
and fracture
the first 15 minutes of their travels
consist of heading in a south easterly
direction gradually identifying
memorized aspects of the environment
such as fauna and rock formations
flanking the wooded path out of town due
to the lack of life forms the only
sounds are crunching leaves as they
progress
it is once a felled tree is spotted that
special operative nix identifies a point
which should be in the north western
area of the town at this point an rem is
hung from a nearby branch special
operative nix walks off the path and
into the woods
to further delineate the area in which
the replicate tembi ends
and the next cell in the grid begins
special operative nix methodically
begins canvassing the woods and
cross-referencing her map placing rems
to delineate the boundaries of the
primary zone
k9121 bounced through the woods
alongside her during this time
occasionally sniffing the area 45
minutes passed uneventfully until k9121
pauses
alert and focused on an area off in the
distance ahead special operative nicks
readies her shotgun and the pair proceed
with caution
up ahead a long gnarled white shape can
be seen snaking through the undergrowth
and between trees partially obscured
beneath scattered leaves and detritus
k9121 approaches within a metre of the
object before halting at special
operative nix's command upon approach
mottled white flesh can be made out as
well as varicose veins running across
its length the appendage trails off far
into the distance and outside the
boundaries of the primary tembi
facsimile on one end the other end
terminates in an average sized foot
nearby
at the besiege of command special
operative nix moves to investigate the
foot which can be seen to spot a
colorful tattoo encircling the shin
closer inspection reveals it to be an
oriental dragon its mouth open and
consuming the tail in an aurora boris
this confirms the identity of the
cadaver as being
d-2172 special operative nix asks
command for orders concerning course of
action
an alarm is set off within the base
command is notified that dr lafayette
has escaped their quarters with the
assistance of d774 a search unit is
deployed and the residents of baseline
tembi are notified of the fugitives
receiving no guidance from command
special operative nix states her
intention to follow d2172 limb through
the woods and into the next cell in the
grid she calls canine one two one to her
side
and they begin walking
three quick bone splintering cracks can
be heard behind the pair special
operative nix quickly turns
drawing her shotgun to see that the
ankle of d2172 has snapped and twisted
such that the foot is raised off the
ground
and slightly coiled toes pointing in her
direction k9121 puts itself in front of
her raises its haunches and emits a low
growl special operative nicks backs away
slowly she puts an additional three
meters between herself and the foot with
no signs of further movement from it she
whistles for canine one two one and they
continue following the limb
the two followed
d-2172's leg for approximately 1.5
kilometers where it then zigzags up a
nearby incline
crossing perpendicular to a dirt path
that ascends a rocky hill
checking her map special operative nix
identifies herself as having arrived at
the base of shallow's peak tembi's
highest point of elevation which lay to
the north of town she attempts to radio
command to no avail then reports that
she will ascend the hill in order to use
the elevation to canvas the area and
provide a sit rep the ascent takes
roughly 20 minutes
dr lafayette is recovered by a tembi
constable after trying to enlist the
help of local police they are brought
back to the base agent collins leaves
the control room in order to aid dr
lafayette and ensure he receives proper
medical care
d-774 was shot and killed during the
confrontation that led to dr lafayette's
capture their remains are returned to
base
cresting the second leg of the hill the
trail can be seen to lead alongside a
rocky wall before ending at the mouth of
a small cave special operative next
notes that this cave does not exist in
baseline tembi as she nears the entrance
the visual feed degrades slightly
k9121 winds quietly
and is assuaged by special operative
nicks
in between static interference the cave
is seen to possess signs of habitation
to the right the walls can be seen to
have been carved to create small shelves
speckled with indiscernible filth an
ancient cast iron lidded pot sits in the
center of the room atop a mound of
partially burnt petrified wood encircled
by rocks on the left discoloration in a
roughly three by one area of the cave's
rear suggests former existence of
bedding in that corner long since rotted
away
special operative nix takes two steps in
before stopping short she looks to k9121
who remains outside the cave entrance
head lightly bowed and its tail tucked
between its legs special operative nicks
heads over to k9121
kneels down and coddles the animal
petting it and commanding it to remain
in place standing back up she moves
inside to check the shelves small bits
of wicker possibly some form of
ornamentation crumble upon being touched
advancing to the pot a carving can be
seen on its side which she inspects she
removes the pot's lid and gags it is
shown to be filled with a murky brown
pool of stagnant water within which
floats several objects unable to be made
out
until special operative knicks activates
her headlamp and gasps at the side of
over a dozen small bones based off of
the most clearly visible of these an
ulna it is estimated that the remains
belong to an individual no more than two
months of age
the display is further plagued by static
special operative nicks replaces the lid
and sets the pot down carefully she
pauses momentarily partly stands and
staggers and then proceeds to fall to
her knees and vomit profusely she curses
quietly and sniffles afterwards for a
minute obscuring the camera feed as she
wipes her face
looking up a small nook in the cave wall
can be seen at foot level beside where
the bed previously lay something small
and brown is inside it special operative
nicks takes a few deep breaths then
raises to a stand
static builds as special operative nix
crosses over to investigate she kneels
places her hand inside
and pulls out the object the visual
field is overcome by white noise though
special operative nicks can still be
heard who reports finding some form of
diary flipping through the first few
weathered pages reveals little of
important any content that may have once
been present has long since faded she
continues to scan the document when a
hollow popping noise rings out
turning quickly no immediate threat or
change in surroundings is seen
k9121 begins approaching cautiously
another sharp wet pop noise is heard
k9121 growls at special operative nicks
and glances about for the noise's source
it sounds off a third time and the lid
of the cast iron pot vibrates as it is
struck from within
special operative nicks flees the cave
with d-774's remains being tended to by
director kim agent collins and dr
lafayette arrive at the control room
agent collins dons the headset and
announces her presence to special
operative knicks
special operative nix has reached the
top of shallow's peak by the time
command is able to reach her and relays
the events of the previous hour from her
perspective she is clearly able to see
both the replicate tembi to the east
where she entered as well as its
iterative copy to the west in the cell
she now occupies in a panoramic shot a
dozen windmills of further tempi
replicates
can be viewed far off in the distance
she explains to command that although
the pattern of the surrounding areas
supports the recursive iteration theory
of this dimension's layout that there
are noted inconsistencies within the
grid she inhabits beyond the cave which
did not exist in baseline or replicate
tembi she points out a small grove of
dead trees that seemingly has no
parallel elsewhere in the grid
similarly special operative nix claims
to have spotted an unidentifiable
structure in the town center of tembi in
her cell
upon query from command as to why there
would be a deviation from the pattern
special operative nix suggests that the
presence of d2172
across the boundary of two iterations
may be causing fluctuations in the
integrity of the grid cell she occupies
likening it to cellular lysis special
operative next explains how the border
between spatial zones could be weakened
by foreign material occupying two cells
in a grid simultaneously for an extended
period of time
a problem that prohibited the building
of outpost 41 with scp
several years prior
despite the instability of this cell
she posits that the defamations in this
zone may be reflections of the
historical state of tembi and therefore
present a valuable research opportunity
that merits further exploration
special operative nix begins her descent
small cracks and pops can be heard still
reverberating within the cave as she
passes
she does not look inside
someone is sobbing
at the bottom of the hill a path of dead
grass and foliage can be seen where
previously
d2172's leg had lane
k9121 sniffs about this area and begins
following the trail further into the
cell
in the direction of the next tembi the
two travel at a steady pace with special
operative nicks checking regularly
behind them
as they progress the forest slightly
darkens as cloud cover obscures the sun
a sharp report of bone snapping echoes
in the distance
special operative nicks holds a shotgun
in a low ready position and double
checks the safety
another crack the splintering of bones
sounds off repeatedly from an
indiscernible source as special
operative nicks levels her weapon
attempting to follow the noise another
crack
small branches and leaves fall and
flitter about as the foot of d-2172
emerges from the canopy dangling from
above it quickly twists and breaks
turning to face special operative necks
with its toes
it is immediately met with three rapid
bursts of bug shot the appendage dangles
loosely dripping blood from its shredded
remains
the foot is almost entirely destroyed
consisting of chunks of flesh suspended
by the ankle with only the posterior and
anterior digits remaining it lulls to
and fro from the concussive force of the
shots swaying impotently
k9121 snarls and barks at the appendage
special operative nix keeps her weapon
trained on it as the two work to
carefully circumvent it
it is as they pass it that the appendage
swiftly plunges into the ground
trailed by several meters of leg the
appendage is swollen from countless
fractures across its length
giving it dozens of points of extra
articulation special operative nicks
breaks into a run as the coiled mass
begins to shift
the two barrel through the forest
k9121 in the lead leaping and dodging
over obstacles in the terrain behind
them a fuhrer of rustling and banging
can be heard as the leg bursts through
the foliage and violently rebounds off
trees tearing through the woods in
pursuit special operative necks takes a
sharp right then it left followed by
another right in an attempt to carve a
path that would have
d2172's leg caught up and tangled
between the trees as k9121 continued on
a more direct route towards town
special operative nix is now alone
there is a crash as the appendage
ricochets off a nearby tree to her right
with the remains of d2172's foot
shooting perpendicular across her path
barring progress as the length of leg
snakes behind it special operative nicks
transitions into a low slide avoiding
collision and fires into the flesh of
the leg the leg convulses as she rolls
raises to her feet ducks beneath the
limb and breaks off running after five
paces the feed shakes as she is struck
from behind and falls face first to the
ground
quickly coming to a kneel her shotgun
can be seen laying several feet away in
the brush as she begins to crawl towards
it there is a quick flash of mottled
flesh across the feed the limb crosses
in front of her once twice three times
special operative knicks groans as the
appendage warps around her looking down
it is clear that her arms are pinned to
her sides her machete lay at her hip
inches from her grasping hand as she
struggles the leg pulls back twisting in
on itself ever further coiling about her
like a snake jerking the feet about as
she is spun backwards into its many
folds
the twirling ceases and special
operative nyx screams
as the limb tightens around her the
remains of d2172's foot comes into view
it hovers before special operative nicks
there is a pair of cracks as the
remaining pinky and big toes splinter
and fracture forming two sharp prongs
that pinpoint her face it rears back
momentarily before it launches forward
just as it is about to strike special
operative nicks there is a flurry of
motion canine one two one leaps from off
camera catching
t2172's foot in its mouth the limb
writhes as the animal wrestles with the
appendage the leg loosens dropping
special operative nicks the appendage
twists and curls as k9121 tears into it
with his teeth quivering in an unnatural
manner special operative nicks crawls
toward her firearm as they contend with
one another in the background she grabs
her gun and turns in time to see the
legs sweep under the feet of canine one
two one wrap around the canine and
retract at a rapid pace the dog yelps as
the limit snares it and absconds off
into the woods away from special
operative nicks
agent collins informs special operative
knicks that she needs to progress
towards the next town she is advised to
not follow the limb and to consider the
animal a lost asset
ignoring command special operative nix
charges after the fleeing leg the knot
of flesh wrapped around canine one two
one shreds a path through the forest
ripping through the brush and felling
some of the smaller trees special
operative nyx curses and pants as she
chases after it the leg begins to draw
itself upward to pull the animal's
weight up alongside it and out of sight
as it drags itself away the mass becomes
caught up between a pair of trees
positioned beside one another k9121
whimpers as the leg constricts in an
attempt to squeeze through
special operative necks catches up
discarding her shotgun and lunging
forward with a swift blow from her
machete there is a high-pitched shriek
in the distance she strikes it again and
again
and again she bellows a long scream as
she viciously assaults the leg
cutting clear into the flesh and
revealing bone
she hacks and chops and shouts
as the dog winds and attempts to free
itself
the leg ceases its attempts to pull
through the trees and instead raises
sharply upwards knocking special
operative nicks away the cries of k9121
can be heard above her before trailing
off into the far distance
out of earshot
someone is sobbing
special operative nix screams in anger
she stands shouting threats off into the
wilderness after the leg crying out for
it to return swearing retribution it
takes several minutes for her to calm
down she radios command
asking for help to hunt the leg of d2172
and is denied she is instructed to
either investigate the tempi in her cell
or abort the mission and chooses the
former she retrieves her firearm and
continues progress
given the distance traveled during the
chase it is not long before she is met
with the farmland which encircles this
version of tembi unlike the baseline
town the farmlands here are barren not a
single piece of vegetation sprouts from
the dirt which is seen to appear dry and
infertile as she treks
onward entering the town special
operative nix stalks silently through
the streets she rounds a corner peering
into the general store as she passes
revealing several scp-783 victims
pressed up against the plate glass there
is still another on the second story of
the hardware store across the street
three more peer out from within a sedan
half parked on the curb
having crashed into a lamppost another
is visible beneath the gate of a storm
drain its face contorted and pressed up
against the bars
with enough force that bits of fat press
upwards through them none move to attack
a sudden cacophony of splintering wood
and breaking glass interrupts the
silence turning around special operative
nix sees that the buildings flanking the
end of the street have taken a broken
crooked appearance
their foundations crumble a hallmark of
scp-783's influence before special
operative nix can react the pair of
buildings collapse inwards blocking the
road she dented from
it is unknown if it is the sudden noise
or the possible presence of scp-783
itself but the corpses spotted through
the town begin to shudder violently the
trio in the car can be seen to thrash
about wildly their bones break and snap
and crack and rapidly heal
and stretch
within seconds the entirety of the sedan
is full of flesh knotted together and
writhing the windshield cracks from the
pressure
d-774 enters the control room
special operative knicks continues
towards the town center it is here that
a major deviation from baseline tembi is
discovered in the center of the
intersection before the steps of the
town hall stands a sizable wooden
platform supported on a large sturdy
base erected in the middle of the
platform as a large rounded contraption
there is an unidentifiable mound upon it
special operative nicks approaches
ascending the stairs
revealing the contraption to be a wheel
with several spokes radiating from its
center the mound is a nude disheveled
human strapped to the device face down
in each area where their limbs cross an
empty space between the wheel spokes the
appendage is gnarled and broken with
their left leg swollen and grossly
extended it trails off the side of the
platform
looking to her right a singular piece of
parchment can be seen nailed to a post
atop the stairs the document is a
sensationalized proclamation of guilt
identifying an individual by the name of
hinja woonibald the paper denounces him
as a highwayman guilty of theft child
murder
witchcraft and cannibalism it finally
goes on to state the ruling of his
punishment asserting that he is to be
broken on the wheel
special operative nicks confirms with
command that they have a clear capture
of the paper's contents before she casts
it aside she takes a moment to retract
her shotgun with slug ammunition and
moves towards the macabre display
prodding the corpse with the barrel of
the gun elicits no response she deftly
circles around to its front to get a
look at its face
nailing down
the visage of d2170
comes into view
his face is bloated features twisted in
agony upon verifying its identity
special operative nix follows the length
of his leg with her camera
seeing it lead off behind a nearby
building she states her intention to
follow it to k9121
but is interrupted by a low moan turning
back the corpse of
d2172's eyes
focus on her she reels backwards and
discharges her weapon due to the close
proximity the shot removes the upper
part of
d2172's head
the body gurgles and seethes as she
stands and fires the next two rounds
down into its trunk causing d2172
to spray a torrent of blood from the
remains of its mouth special operative
nyx recoils as she is coated in these
fluids stumbling back there is a
sickening crack
as the lower jaw of d2172 contorts and
lengthens
along the right side
and another snap as the left half breaks
and extends three more cracks see the
jawline widening
and lengthening it lashes out as she
attempts a quick load just missing her
face and spraying yet more blood that
obscures the feed the sound of special
operative knicks hurriedly descending
the staircase is heard
while there can be seen to be movement
on the camera feed no details are
discernible the next several minutes
consists primarily of audio as special
operative knicks evades and combats the
ever-breaking jaw of d-2172
all that can be heard are her shouts and
cries the breaking and splintering of
bone and the sound of rent flesh as
special operative knicks fends off the
attack with her machete in the midst of
the struggle a lone shotgun blast rings
out the weapon can be heard clattering
to the ground
before all falls silent
the feed is darkened as special
operative nix rubs the camera clearing
it to the best of her ability it will
remain smeared for the remainder of
filming but the aftermath of the
struggle can be seen
the jaw of d2172 stretches from his
corpse
and chris crosses through the
intersection blood blankets the majority
of the area and several teeth are
visible having been knocked from the gum
line special operative knicks is panting
and heaving she looks down
revealing that she lost an index finger
on her right hand
she swears as she covers it with her
free hand
in an attempt to stem the bleeding
she canvasses to the ground for the lost
digit which is then spotted laying
several feet away as she rushes towards
it it seizes and wriggles
snapping and beginning to elongate
special operative nicks turns to retreat
dipping down mid-ron to grab her firearm
as she flees
despite prodding from command special
operative nix does not return to the
execution platform to scour for more
evidence she instead rushes along the
length of the leg trailing from
d2172's corpse she curses over the radio
at agent collins casting her helmet
aside the last that is scene of special
operative nicks is her running down a
length of road
alongside
d-2172's leg she follows it around the
corner
several minutes pass uneventfully the
leg of d2172 then shifts and gyrates
slapping the ground with excessive force
for approximately 30 seconds before
becoming still
a minute later the lens spontaneously
cracks
there is heavy breathing
someone is sobbing
the area darkens as it is cast in shadow
the feed terminates as the camera is
destroyed
special operative knicks is deemed
absent without leave
with the nature of the dimension fully
understood it is determined that a fully
armed force would be required for the
capture or elimination of scp-783
scp-783-l-3
mobile task force deployed to contain
scp-783
pending declassification
scp-783-l4
okay
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
tomothy
anvil
zargaran
professor puffer
spencer j tilp
will rimmer
vino
gevios the hollow
zazzapan
k
dr briggs
tailored printers
cignar
alatreon
your local foundation agent
derivative
boy
a real american hebrew
the morrigan
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash
the vulgan
thank you
you